voilà ce qu'a dit julien julien 11 ans
il est en sixième à 1 au collège
théodore monod de sa dumont et il a dit
mes parents sont séparés depuis un an je
vis maintenant ici avec maman et ma
soeur on va fêter les 18 ans de ma soeur
à la salle des fêtes de vialle on habite
tous là bas chez papy nani sauf mon père
par contre je ne peux jamais joué devant
la maison dans le jardin car on a peur
que l'autre viennent
papy se met à crier quand ils le voient
et c'est pas bon pour sa santé quand il
vient je maintiens que maman parce qu'il
veut juste de lui faire du mal juste ça
c'est pas un père et c'est pour ça que
je suis un homme mes parents divorcent
joséphine au ciel ne l'aiment pas mais
elle n'est pas obligée de le voir vu
qu'elle est grande
moi aussi je ne veux plus jamais voir et
je ne veux pas que le juge m'oblige à
aller avec une semaine sur deux ou un
week-end sur deux parce que je ne veux
plus voir plus jamais je n'ai plus rien
à ajouter voilà bien mettre dhabi mais
je vous écoute j'ai l'impression que vos
enfants sont remontés contre vous
monsieur vous pouvez expliquer ça
j'aimerais bien qu'on prend je sais pas
ce qu'on met dans la tête